e che cosa con tirato fuori dove di
solito stories a grandissima richiesta
nuovissimi scherzi alla maestra cattiva
scarichi terme sempre lasciate un bel mi
piace le volete che anche vitale passa
gli scherzi nel suo canale lasciato un
bel mi piace su questo video e poi
andate a vedere i video nel canale
digitale di rilascio alla fine di queste
viti avete visto il video presidenti
andate poi a vederli oggi faremo degli
scherzi anche con lo slice più bella che
competono per divertente sempre
frenetico corn mettetevi comodi e
iniziamo subito primo scherzo spiriti
share non deve vedere la luce taglia le
gambe del tavolo così lei cade e non può
abbronzarsi fuori nel suo giardino del
suo terrazzo vediamo che dice sta
andando
[Risate]
wow che ginnasta possiamo tagliare le
gambe del dry in realtà non è uno
spettacolo straio non vedo l'ora di
vedere scritti tor che cade proprio
lavoro ti raccomando voi parlate sempre
le camere in sicurezza così potete
vedere
se stiamo per essere prese o no visto
che noi ci sono citazioni dimentichiamo
di guardia ma ora cercherò di
controllarle meglio allora lei sta
entrando dentro casa eccola è sempre
nella cassettina cassetta degli attrezzi
che sembra intanto questa mattina
prendiamo a tagliare le gambe della
sedia
dalle camere di sicurezza mi sembra che
lei al piano di sopra forse possiamo
abbiamo mai toccate io mi avevano
bisogno ha cambiato colore vanta una
guardia sollevazione dall'asta scongiura
la porta per ok ora aspettiamo solo
william harvey eccola eccola ragazzi
sociale scalano vedete è caduta su
d'italia che questo è stato abbastanza
facile
aggiungi del colorante colore al mondo
di scary teacher facendola esplodere il
camino di senso di tutti così santo
crisi che c'è tanto prendeva iaccarino
comunque penso di aver capito che cosa
utilizzare per fare questo scherzo è
tutta dinamite no io sono passato la
benzina
penso che tutti lo contenderanno beni
non vedo l'ora di vedere scrittice spero
che le brucia i capelli che gli
rimangono i capelli dritti ed in alcuni
altri scherzi dalle camere non riesco a
capire e non era stata fatta avanti a
noi e proprio davanti al camino sarà
l'altro proprio il quadro descritto ha
una faccia cattivissima aiuto forse ha
sentito qualcosa che insieme al vicino
piace anche la dinamica però abbiamo
tenuto dopo un altro aspetto abbiamo via
libera per andare al cav i nomi come
capita di rado tirati girati ad aggi
[Musica]
spegnerlo puoi metterlo benzini
aspettare che le tornate riesce o non ho
fatto ma che siamo tornati in cucina ora
dobbiamo cercare l'acqua dove può essere
ora direi di uscire dove sfruttano però
credo che lei sia proprio qui non ci
sono racconti sono proprio perché allora
piaceva meglio quale abbiamo spegniamo
il fuoco perché perfetta vediamo la
benzina
ho mancato un rimando non abbiamo potuto
può mettere il fuoco d'artificio
ho messo la benzina però ok considerato
spesso notiamo come dovresti viso
andando al fuoco
speriamo che non è accesa e si abbiamo
dalle finestre mentre stavamo scappando
veniva detto che non capisco come mai il
fuoco si sia spento
che cosa ha scritto permettere lo slime
nella vasca da bagno dispongono mette li
fai battito eccola ecco l'intro che sta
facendo
sto andando a fare il bagno vestita sta
facendo largo allora innanzitutto
dobbiamo trovare lo chiama gello che
andrebbe gelatina l'acquisto di raimo
penso che possa essere in cucina sopra
non vedo l'ora di vederla immerge
bloccato cristo per ora scorso video
abbiamo visto che lei in tv guarda a se
stessa
abbiamo detto ma che strano come me ne
vorrà se stessa in tv e se avete detto
che in realtà lei guarda se stessa che
il calo all isola che si che fa la
lezione de cattiva con gli alunni nonno
perché non si si eh sì nomale cresce
troppo vicino aiuto di stupirlo
astronomico cena proprio perché ha
sentito i rumori giusto il tempo sta
vicino
[Musica]
perché e cosa trovo sempre migliore no
non è questo come no mi sa di no no non
è questo ma di a2
credo però siamo vicini al secondo me
siamo vicini dovremmo e secco vicino
però di dati qui si arrivi subito si sia
mosso questo questo ok ok aprì la porta
si metti la gelatina dice di coprirlo
con qualcosa ne fa vicino non so prendo
questo criminoso che cos'è per avere una
moglie così non lo vede primo ok oretta
banca posto purtroppo poi scappare dalla
finestra che aspetta aspetta
[Musica]
ok bravo sì perché letta proprio
arrivando da lì
ma io mi sono fatto male vediamo come
reagiscono sliven nella vasca da bagno
in questo la più difficile tutto con
tutti i vestiti sarà un pò prossimo
scherzo a una puzzolente che è un odore
terribile che arriva dalla bomba
puzzolente da fioretta se nel tuo
puzzole decide con la personalità di
scary teacher che è un restano quindi
butta là nella sauna e così le iso ma
sarà nella sauna con la bongo puzzolo
[Musica]
facendo dell'esercizio tematico quando
balla adesso dobbiamo cercare questa
scaletta puzzolente arriviamo sta nella
solita cassetta degli attrezzi non si
vede niente qui no non ci credo
il pilota che può scappa scappa
mi scappa subito le scale ma uffa
portati in una cosa a testa per mentire
se ne intende riprendo così tutto da
rifare tutto addosso perché li sa come
la battuta la testa ha dimenticato che
noi eravamo più che ora dobbiamo
metterla senza stau da quando c'è una
stessi giudici quindi dobbiamo salire
sopra all'asta una per buttare dentro la
fialetta puzzolente
forse dobbiamo farlo prima che arrivi
lei e vado nella sauna altrimenti no ce
lo facciamo prima poi rete ne accorge si
no ho visto la foto perché no sono la
finestra
che strana o no no no io vedo quando
questi si programmato dalla bottiglia
vedi perché l'inter non è tanto grave
vista la finestra si aspetta aspetta
facciamo la prima andare così almeno
possiamo agire indisturbati ecco una lei
è entrato nella sanno dobbiamo sbrigarci
mentre lei nella sauna tutta vestita non
l'ha già de graval beh comodo ma
vogliamo che fa che sono cimentati già
ci ha visto dalla finestra figurati
dall'asta una si vedrebbe sicuramente
perché dice il fumo tanto della sauna il
cuore
ok ok dobbiamo quando veniamo questo ha
detto pensavo di riuscire a questo
scherzo abbiamo fallito perché lei è
riuscito a scappare come facciamo allora
forse dobbiamo bloccare la porta allora
è vero dobbiamo chiudere la porta
ok abbiamo rifatto il livello di tale ha
ripreso del bomboletta puzzolente questa
volta quando una volta che lei entra
nella fauna noi chiuderemo la porta da
fuoco è uscito però va in crisi se fuori
abbiamo provato a cercare se c'era
qualche lucchetto qualcosa sparso in
giro ma non lo abbiamo trovato quindi
sicuramente dobbiamo chiudere con la
trave di legno che se fuori così rimarrà
incastrata dentro di noi siamo la
bomboletta puzzolente e forse riusciamo
a superare il livello
ok li entrata nell'occhio quindi
possiamo andare e chiuderla dentro prima
degli lab una bombola si vede che c'è la
trave senza succedere dobbiamo vediamo
vediamo
questa volta non ce la farà a sfuggirci
[Musica]
sai che puzza fialetta puzzolente in
seguito ce l'abbiamo fatta
e allora scrittice sta aspettando
impazientemente un pacco
quindi facciamo un aspettare un po di
più ma che era successo tra l'altro la
casa di scheletri nazionale art poi quel
cambio nel nostro bello artistico sera
ha sentito il comando la casa per 7 è
fatta tra le nuvole e al telefono stava
parlando con il corriere e lì ha detto
nel mio costume di halloween come è il
ritardo di due giorni non è possibile
il corriere ho sentito la voce di
spiriti cerco si fastidiosa e antipatica
ed è arrivato un impacco vedi sì però mi
devo allontanare perché lei è proprio
passo pro di novellino che c'è scritto
che dobbiamo trovare un nido di vespe e
di stare attenti perché pongono allora
poi ricordiamo già che l'altra volta
quando ombre ragno essere attenti perché
punge
bisogna trovare dei guanti altrimenti ci
preso lei non riusciamo a prendere sta
dormendo
[Musica]
ecco infatti sei già svelata a me sembra
che lì si sveglia si renda conto che
stai per il rumore essere comunque
dobbiamo trovare prima i guanti poi li
nido di vespe che sarà un albero e
mancino abbiamo uno scooter
sicuramente ci servirà per richiudere il
pacco è vero bravo ciò che io controllo
le camere
noi a 38 bene manovale abbiamo ancora un
pochino di tempo sta salendo si sta
facendo
non ce la faccio passare perché c'è una
statua non fa c'era stato bisogno la
lingua è un'altra forte vento che ha
perso di vista
rimane in qualche modo controlla se poi
qualche albero al nido di vespe albero
guarda dalla paura e con pamela sottile
davvero solo prenderlo dalla su proviamo
quelle scala non si può fronte si potrà
prendere la scala è vero con la scala
lei ovviamente si sta come sempre
ammirando davanti allo specifico
prendere guarda piano resta la scala dai
veneti che fossero posizionato un po
male forse non lo verso la porta ma che
non piace a te carotta ok bravo bravo
bravo ci guardiamo su un albero aiuto e
servizi in testa dobbiamo essere veloce
prima mi posso l'albero ma guarda te li
si sta rincorrendo ma noi siamo
sull'albero
[Musica]
[Applauso]
20 st periti per non ci puoi prendere
perché siamo to live che stava tagliando
facile prenderlo a ok
eccoli meno male che l'erba vedo nemmeno
lingua ho finito l'energia però mi devo
sbrigare o no è proprio lì non c'è
ancora qualche parte dobbiamo aspettare
che lei stanno al piano di sopra perché
il parco e al piano di sotto
ed è proprio lì adesso non abbiamo
energia da moretti è la fine non
potevate fare
ok è così di luca speriamo di farcela
questa maxi ciao ho sognato il pacco
utili primo aprirla centro che che cosa
c'era dentro tralascerò
quindi l'abbiamo fatto sì che essa sia
se non cambiamo che cala moresca
non vedo l'ora di vedere scheri titolo
con tutta la vespa week
[Musica]
ma che cosa ha tirato fuori tutto
favorire ed ecipar è stato il vostro
terzo preferito per me questo è anche
quello dello slide la vasca da bagno
a me quello della saur è stato un po
difficile all'inizio giocava un gioco
che ho visto però che puzza cappuccio
scriveteci miei commenti vostre
preferite ora cliccate in una di queste
quattro castellina provvedere i nostri
altri video cliccando su quella che
preferite
[Musica]